bonjour à tous aujourd'hui vous avez de
la chance vous êtes des chanceux
aujourd'hui vous allez gagner
la coque de votre smartphone hors pas
n'importe quel coque on parle pas de
coke pâtes et riz dont parle de gope
vrai monstre ongs des choses très très
très solide et vous allez voir c'est des
coques en partenariat avec la marque
spec
on va en parler je vais vous les montrez
vous expliquer comment ça marche et vous
allez gagner votre corps en tout cas
quatre d'entre vous donc rester
connectés en garde ça non plus
[Musique]
alors dans la série des concours
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de la
marque
peck spex est une marque que j'ai déjà
rencontré il n'y a pas très longtemps à
barcelone au mwc et qu'il ya des
produits qui sont cools intéressant pour
protéger vos smartphones aux tablettes
aux ordinateurs et plein de produits
auxquels vous tenez
alors l'idée aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement nous faire gagner quatre
coques
alors on en a quatre ici en présentation
on va les regarder ensemble vous allez
voir elles sont très très cool je vais
vous les faire gagner pour les gagner
vous allez voir c'est extrêmement simple
je vous donnerai le détail d'ici
quelques instants
dans la vidéo donc restez connectés
alors je vous montre un petit peu ces
coques moi j'ai pris des coques m'a
demandé des coques pour iphone 6 asselah
presidio de spec
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
voudrait comme des produits qui sont
fait vraiment pu être hyper résistant là
votre smartphone il peut tomber de trois
mètres marqué l'allier il peut tomber de
trois mètres sans qu'ils se cassent sans
rien mordue antichoc protection mince
supérieur dont il a produit moi je
trouve assez cool je mets mon iphone
dedans c'est mignon c'est sûrement c'est
vraiment très sympa ça c'est vraiment
classique pourquoi pas se mentir
ah si vous avez effectivement ici de
petites encoches là et ça se voit bien
par la mare bon après voilà c'est très
sobre tient maintenant la main ça
fonctionne donc ça c'est la coque numéro
un quand numéro deux c'est l'après vidéo
ball est intéressant parce qu'il fait
ranger votre carte bleue dedans et oui
on part en soirée et qu'on n'a pas de
poche qu'on n'a pas envie de s'embêter
c'est souvent cadet des mecs de croiser
souvent mon cas ça vous avez donc un
grand portefeuille vous mettez votre
smartphone de droit m ça rajoute de
l'épaisseur on est par contre ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'effectivement je
peux ranger jusqu'à trois cartes bleues
ici et au moins je les ai toujours avec
moi alors si vous perdez votre
smartphone vous perdez tout l'argent le
smartphone à total et à vous êtes bien
embêté mais je trouve cependant en tout
cas que que l'udps est plutôt pas mal
c'est vraiment intéressant troisième cox
et l'a présidé au grip art grimm pascal
effectivement de lentilles dérapant pour
éviter effectivement qu'elle ne se barre
vraiment tentation de robustesse avec ce
truc là c'est pas mal alors j'étais à
préciser cette vidéo n'est pas du tout
comme cerise
c'est juste pour vous gâter vous le
faire gagner quand on a proposé de
parler des coques j'ai dit écoutez les
moins why not sa ponette à la sambre
parler de coke par contre on va parler
de coqs qui est un intérêt elle
intéresse effectivement vous puissiez
les gagner parce que vous montrez des
codes pour vous montrer les crocs je
voyais pas trop l'intérêt
1 - qui est vraiment un truc
révolutionnaire là les produits sont
très bien mais ils sont pas
révolutionnaires
donc c'est intéressant on évite d'en
parler on vous gâte à voilà tout
simplement
donc là effectivement un côté
antidérapant je sais pas si il trouve
que c'est plutôt plutôt cool plutôt bien
c'est donc celle là c'est la président
de rim
et voici la présidente lire bon bah ça
c'est effectivement une coque
entièrement transparente quand vous
devez regarder votre smartphone vous
voulez une bonne protection quelque
chose de solide et que vous voulez
toujours profiter de l'aspect esthétique
de votre smartphone ça c'est top
voilà c'est brillant on voit bien iphone
est ce ça marche c'est sympa toujours le
petit logo spec en haut ça fonctionne
plutôt pas mal donc effectivement moi je
trouve ça plutôt plutôt cool c'est jolie
coque pour gagner l'une de ces coques
c'est pas très compliqué en ce qu'il
faut que vous fassiez sais que vous
allez voir en bas vous avez un lien un
formulaire à remplir la toute première
chose j'ai tiré c'est très important
c'est d'une d'être abonné à la chaîne
bien évidemment ne serait ce que pour
être tenu au courant des prochains
concours qui arrive
le deuxième c'est de mettre un like
directement sur cette vidéo vous mettez
des pousses vers les eaux des pousses
des pousses d'épouser pouces que des
pousses de partout donc vous ne mettez
en pousse vers le haut vous allez sur
twitter et vous m'en voyez un petit
tweet pour me dire pourquoi vous devriez
le gagner avec le hashtag greu ne gâtent
le hashtag il est marqué en bas greu me
gâte et puis ensuite vous avez un lien
en bas directement vous cliquez dessus
et vous remplissez le formulaire dans
lequel je vais vous demander à votre nom
d'utilisateur sur youtube vous demander
votre nom sur twitter pour les hashtags
ils ont bien été postées tout ça tout ça
enfin voilà quelques informations votre
adresse pour effectivement vous la faire
parvenir ne vous inquiétez pas ce
fichier c'est moi qu'ils gardent je ne
le vends pas je n'en fais pas commerce
donc rassurez vous pouvez y aller
tranquillement y'a pas de soucis il n'y
a pas d'embrouillé
comme on dit chez nous donc voila merci
j'espère que ça vous plaît moi je les
trouve cool c'est petit coquin je
m'étais dit l'écouté quitte à parler
d'un produit puisque on sollicite pour
en parler et bien l'idée c'est
effectivement de vous les faire gagner
on ne sollicite pas mal pour parler de
produits faut pas forcément toujours
l'intérêt donc je décline la plupart du
temps je vois pas trop l'intérêt ya des
trucs des fois où des chargeurs sans fil
on me propose je vois pas trop l'intérêt
l'intérêt réel ainsi au final je dois
quitter ce genre de choses
une fonction non rémunérée à jour à sion
une fois de plus l'idée c'est
effectivement de vous en faire profiter
servir de vous les faire gagner
et là à mon sens il ya un vrai intérêt
donc voilà donc j'espère que ces petits
cadeaux vous feront plaisir un marque
mango commentaires dites moi si vous
voulez trouver 2 cuil
il y en a quatre il y en a quatre à
gagner vous verrez dans le formulaire
je vous demander lequel vous souhaitez
gagner pour vous ayez le produit qui
vous plaisent je peux vous envoyer
n'importe quel produit ou un hasard donc
rassurez vous les bateaux si tout est
très bien fait ça que réfléchie ils
étaient deux pans centre derrière tout
ça vous allez voir vous allez choisir
votre code fourni tous meilleurs se voir
et puis après on s'occupe de tout un
merci à vous merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo comme d'hab je vais essayer de
vous gâter régulièrement de faire plein
de cadeaux quelque chose comme ça donc
rester connecté on va parler beaucoup de
produits tech de produits innovants et
énormément de choses d'ici quelques
temps on va retourner un petit peu en
voyage aller voir si face à droite à
gauche valais va rien faire plein de
choses cool qui arrive vous dit pas tout
je regarde un petit peu de suspense
ainsi je vous dévoile tout aujourd'hui
s'il fera plus de plaisir voilà on garde
toutes ces infos je vous invite comme
d'hab à nous laisser vos commentaires
suggestions tout ce que vous voulez
directement ballet like bien évidemment
les pousse les bisous
les abonnements la totale vous y allez
vous vous privez pas je suis toujours
très friands de ce genre de choses donc
voila merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo que les meilleurs gagnent
les quatre gagnants bien évidemment
seront annoncés sur les réseaux sociaux
puis fracture et moi directement
merci à vous soyez sages à très bientôt
portez vous bien et que les meilleurs
gags [ __ ]
[Musique]